President Biden getting called out for
ducking Democratic leaders and ignoring
the surging migrant crisis in America's
biggest city mayor Eric Adams unloading
on the president for snubbing him during
Biden's trip to the Big Apple
I'm very public everybody knows who I am
we're released if we're going to be with
um in the president or not there's still
an opportunity for him to look at The
Roosevelt Hotel like the Hispanic
Congressional Delegation did several
days ago it may look like you're
avoiding each other while he's here I
don't search through a thesaurus to find
a politically correct way of saying you
are hurting me you are hurting my city
if that's what someone is doing
the president in town for
feeding but also had ample time to get
dinner with his family at a fancy
restaurant attend multiple fundraisers
including a star-studded Broadway for
Biden campaign fundraising event and tie
up the traffic for hours and hours at a
time but the crisis is getting harder to
ignore ten thousand migrants crossing
the border yesterday alone forcing Eagle
Pass Texas to declare a state of
emergency and Karin Jean-Pierre losing
her cool when pressed on how the
president plans to deal with it
so what do you call it here at the White
House when 10 000 people illegally cross
the border in a single day so what do
you call it Peter when GOP puts forth a
wait no no no no no no no no no you
can't I'm answering okay we're gonna
move no no no no no no no we're moving
on the background
no no I tried to answer Peter I tried to
answer the question you stopped me let's
go okay I'm gonna stay actually with the
Border
um how many people coming into this
country illegally is enough I know the
numbers but enough for what and not just
to stop the Flop as I mentioned this is
a problem that's been around for some
time now for decades a broken system
Jessica does that make you want to
scream
it doesn't make me feel great
I just think that this the conversation
around it and the White House Press
briefing room and what's going on in the
ground can just all be managed much
better no one is expecting that a
Democratic president is going to
completely reverse his policies writ
large and say you know what I want a a
solid wall because I have seen a lot of
people climbing through the Border walls
so that's not even managing to stop
folks
um I understand why Eric Adams is making
the case that President Biden was here
and he should have met with him about it
um there were a lot of things that were
obviously on the president's docket I
don't think that anyone should not be
able to have dinner with their family or
go to a fundraise well yeah it's a
normal many days and but it's obviously
not
it was a snub one that he is entitled to
make one that many presidents make when
they don't want to deal with it but now
that you have Kathy hokel giving
interviews where she was like enough is
enough we need to do more work
permitting which I do think is a major
step forward in all this she's like we
gotta close up shop here and you're
gonna have more Democrats saying that
and it is going to become more of a
headache for him what about the work
permits just because that's not going to
stop the flow are you kidding me 472
000 Venezuelans just got temporary
protected status so that they could work
and with that they get Social Security
numbers and with that social security
number you know what they can do they
can get a license and with that then
they can register to vote let's not
Kenny that is true that is not true you
know what there are several points but
there are several points of
identification that you can use to
register to vote one is a social
security number and one is a license now
let me finish when Biden says he's done
more to secure the border and deal with
the issue of immigration according to
Kareem Jean-Pierre than anyone that is
so not true it turns out that this past
month of September and we're not even
done yet will be the highest number of
illegals coming through the border so
the question is why are we not enforcing
the law and why you know everybody wants
a blame everyone else there's enough
blame to go around how do you stop this
you stop it by closing the Border you
stop it by not letting them come in you
stop it and Joe Biden did everything he
could to make sure that this thing could
have been that this country can be
invaded and we are being invaded he got
rid of title 42 he got rid of romaina
Mexico he stopped the wall uh he's
cutting the the Texas razor wild the
economic impact of a country like ours
where we are what 33 trillion dollars in
debt and we're running a 1.3 trillion
dollar deficit now we have to pay for
Education medication housing we don't
even know where to put these people and
the president can't meet with the mayor
of one of the biggest cities and most
wealthy cities in the country one of the
most influential cities because this is
what he wants
is interesting to see this Detachment
from the issue like the White House
trying to just say there's no problem
here when you can just see it with your
own eyes it's like the question when
they say oh nobody actually thinks the
president's too old to be president it's
like you know people see things with
their own eyes and with Bill malusian's
reporting one of the only places you can
see it is here yeah it's like almost
like you can't believe them you know
when you when you question elections and
they laugh at you and it's like why
should I believe you oh you're an idiot
and then with your own eyes you see that
they're lying they're gaslighting you
and I hate that word who controls the
border the president Ergo Joe Biden is
not president because he doesn't control
the Border someone else is in charge who
is pushing open borders regardless of
consequences to American citizens
probably the same person who's behind
the abdication of of uh law enforcement
or homelessness all these three uh items
fall into the same bucket a dissent into
chaos uh to overturn a country it's not
the migrants fault who wouldn't want to
come here you know they're incentivized
they're invited by this other invisible
president and they're promised free
stuff right and Joe is an old vessel
just happy to be there evacuous
figurehead and uh it's not accidental if
you look at it if you look at it again
put it next to the crime problem put it
next to the homeless problem doing
nothing at all to stabilizes the country
and in order to have a country a stable
country you have to have a border so why
are we not having a border because we
want to destabilize the country and the
worst part about Biden he has no idea
what he's doing what what he doesn't
care he's just happy to wear the The
Aviator sunglasses and fly in a private
jet Just Like Jesse and what about the
the White House just refusing to answer
or suggesting they were going to answer
a question by being flipping and
sarcastic about it but not actually
giving you the American people answers
about what their policy is well because
they don't have a policy they don't have
Solutions Joe sees this as an
opportunity and here's why the birth
rate in this country is only 1.7 their
calculation is instead of encouraging
American birth they are bringing in
Latin America to
increase our birth rate because a
country with a rising birth rate has to
be over 2.1 directly tied to National
Economic power the second thing wages
they were exploding under Donald Trump
2019 it was like a five thousand dollar
raise that cuts into corporate profits
so I believe what happened was Corporate
America the CIA is the front for
Corporate America Joe Biden's donor
aligned with the cartels and they just
created this conveyor belt of new
workers into the country to drop down
wages so Corporate America could have
thicker profits
and this is the stupidest reason he just
wanted to do the opposite of Donald
Trump yeah I think that's the dumbest
reason but he was I'm not Trump I'm
going to do the opposite which is open
it up there's also really stupid
calculation this is the one that's dumb
that he thought this would appeal to
American Hispanic voters that they would
say oh Joe Biden such a Humane policy
it's actually turning them off to it and
then the other thing is he just wanted
to turn Texas blue the Castro Brothers
have admitted it consumers admitted it
they want to flood it with Hispanic
voters eventually in a degeneration it's
going to go blue and the Republicans
will never have the Electoral juice to
win the White House so you are admitting
though that undocumented people in this
country are not voting in elections
you're admitting it's their kids what
I'm admitted though is well in
Pennsylvania if you get a Social
Security number to the driver's license
you get an automatic ballot sent to your
house you you vote getting a tax ID
number is not the same thing as getting
a social security number but they're
getting Social Security numbers that's
and that's a pull to the other
immigrants who are coming in all right
to be continued by a lot all right
coming at the author of a sexually
explicit book that can be found in
public schools around the country says
Republicans are right hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else